welcome back to Tipping Point I'm your
host Ry Lewis filling in for Karen
mckenny tell me if this sounds familiar
to you a right-wing or Conservative
candidate seems well on the path toward
electoral Victory but then the
establishment and farle joined forces to
thwart that victory unleashing rioter in
the streets their Unholy Union is sealed
by lawfare attacks against the one
candidate from the opposing side who
ever had a chance to defeat them am I
talking about President Trump or Francis
Marine Le Pen honestly it could be
either but in this case it's actually Le
Pen and not Trump after her National
rally party had promising success in the
first round of recent voting in that
country French president Emanuel macron
crawled into bed with literal socialists
and Communists in order to mitigate the
amount of seats her party was able to
gain thus ensuring that the only party
in that country opposed to mass
migration will not have a seat in the
new governing Coalition and now like
clockwork a campaign Finance
investigation has been opened into
leen's 2022 run for President we don't
know much more than that as of now only
that the the allegations include
embezzlement forgery and fraud which is
pretty vague but perhaps that's the
point of lawfare right so that no one
ever really knows what is happening or
why and told you that this all sounds
very familiar to you uh and familiar to
me and now over in Germany you now have
even the courts arguing that membership
in the afd the alternative for Germany
is grounds for that person to not be
able to legally obtain a firearm this
latest ruling comes on the heels of
similar recent rulings allowing for afd
to be debanked as in to have their bank
accounts Frozen at certain financial
institutions and for them to be
surveilled in at least two German states
as suspected right-wing extremist
members we've also discussed on the show
how one of their politicians was
actually fined and convicted of hate
speech for pointing out that more young
girls in the country are raped or
sexually harassed by migrant men than by
German men so as you can see the Common
Thread here with Germany and with what
is happening to Leen and her party in
neighboring France is that the parties
which oppose the mass migration of
Islamic peoples into Europe who oppose
open borders who oppose economic and
cultural globalism who oppose gender
queer ideology and everything else the
left stands for are being met with brute
political force by the very same people
who claim that they are fighting for
democracy the left doesn't like
democracy too much in case you couldn't
tell and when Le Pen's party got too
popular the elites swooped right in in
Germany the same thing as this new piece
from The Blaze explains quote clearly
something about the party has begun to
Res resonate with Germans in recent
years after all the afd gained six seats
and placed second with 15.9% of the
national vote in the European
parliamentary elections last month
handily beating German Chancellor Olaf
schulz's establishment Social Democratic
party according to Reuters the party's
membership has also grown by 60% since
January 2023 the German powers that be
have worked to neutralize the afd's
gains at the polls end quote the
question about Europe and if it can be
saved is still a pertinent one by the
way our next guest tonight is here to
weigh in as well joining us now to
discuss the latest or this latest
article uh for him is or for the stream
I should say titled Vienna a case study
of the great replacement is its author
Raymond Ibrahim the author of Defenders
of the West the Christian Heroes who
stood against Islam Raymond thank you
very much for being here tonight I
really appreciate your time good to be
with you Riley so there's a lot of
interesting stuff in your piece about
Vienna and this this great replacement
that's happening not just in America but
also in places like in Western Europe
which has been traditionally for hunt
for centuries at this point a Christian
Place influenced and inspired by the
word of God and Christian moral
principles so this great replacement
that's going on in Europe could you talk
to us more about it and especially with
Vienna with the rising Muslim population
and and the student population and the
declining population of people that are
Christians as
well sure absolutely well Vienna the
reason I actually wrote about it
recently is a new a new poll came out or
statistics essentially saying that there
are the most most of the Muslims most of
the students in the city of Vienna are
Muslims in the public schools they far
outweigh any other religion including
Catholicism which is the historic
religion of Austria and Vienna as well
um and you know why Vienna is especially
noteworthy I'll get into that but it's
the same all throughout Europe as you're
sort of alluding to I mean uh you know
if you look into Oslo or in Amsterdam or
in Brussels or so many other European
capitals the number one name of newborn
baby boys is Muhammad okay so that
itself is indicative uh as to the
demographic shift that I'm discussing uh
but in Vienna it's interesting because
when you really delve into it and look
not only is there such a massive Muslim
population but it really started going
up it went up 20% from 20,000 sorry from
2017 to about now to 20 23 or 24 20% but
when you go and look at what was going
on in 20 in 2017 it was actually
horrific um I I quote from one report
that came out in 2017 that just shows
you that it's just bedum in Vienna that
Muslim migrant gangs are just in
hoodlums are destroying the place
churches are constantly being attacked
people in the street are being attacked
wi sex grune rape have skyrocketed etc
etc um and it's the same by the way you
were talking about France you know a
statistic I just came across recently
you know really highlights what's going
on but 70% of all prison inmates in
France are Muslim migrants okay so it's
really the same thing in Austria and all
these other Western Nations but in as
much as it was so bad in 2017 the only
thing that happened is the authorities
brought in more Muslim migrants to the
point that Vienna and other cities in
Austria are have a majority of Muslims
now and if you go or you see these
places they're like you're walking
around in Mecca essentially this does
not look in any way shape or form uh
like Vienna remember Vienna historically
was the cultural center Music Center uh
you know Arts religion it was the seat
of the Holy Roman Empire for some time
uh so it's rather ironic and even in
1683 the largest Muslim army ever to
invade and besiege a Christian city was
Vienna and it was about 200,000 Turks of
the Ottoman Empire and it took great
Bloodshed and War and fighting back
winged aars literally a Polish Cavalry
largest Cavalry force in history to
descend and meet this uh match and yet
here are austrians and here are
Europeans going out of their way to
bring in the historic enemy who has not
in any way shape or form reformed U but
has actually become more aggressive
seeing the weakness of the Europeans and
taking over and exploiting and I was
reading in Austria as well you know the
police and the authorities what they do
one woman was actually sexually harassed
or possibly raped the police responded
by telling her not to go out late at
night and possibly to diee her blonde
air dark because apparently the migrants
have a pensions for fair-haired
women and uh in Catholic schools
traditionally Catholic schools Catholics
now have to learn Islamic prayers to
make Muslims feel comfortable and you
know if you really want to underscore
what's going on try to where is this
happening in any other region of the
world other than in the West in Europe
and historically Christian or if you
will white Nations it's I mean it's
mind-boggling imagine you know Europeans
going to Saudi Arabia and forcing
Europeans out and terrorizing I'm sorry
forcing Saudis out and taking over
cities and destroying it and and
destroying mosques I mean can you I it's
in Saudi Arabia you can't even have a
single Church our great friend and Ally
um and also when you look at the
population the white population is
something like 3% or 4 per in the world
and yet is historically white nations
are the ones who are expected to give
away their land their culture their
Heritage their religion their everything
or else they're bad racists and uh it's
just nobody ever sees it the other way
around and probably the worst point is
that this is actually happening with the
acquiescence of Europeans and and
Western Nations and that's why it's
somewhat hard to muster enough sympathy
because this has never happened
historically where people go out of
their way and essentially commit suicide
under the guise of whatever wokeness
political correctness multiculturalism
but it's happening in Austria it's
happening all throughout Western Europe
in France as you just mentioned um you
know all the Muslims there who like I
told you 70% of the inmates are Muslims
uh and you know it's the same thing in
France it's even worse because it's one
of the oldest Nations to take in Muslims
and it has the largest Muslim population
in all of Europe at about 10% which is
pretty hefty um but they agreed to join
in with this leftwing coalition to
defeat Le Pen's party and they all hate
each other you know I mean the Muslims
don't like the left-wing radical
Socialist Communist and vice versa but
once again you see it's just an alliance
of convenience for the true enemy which
is whatever you want to call
conservatism Traditional Values Etc yeah
now there is a war on the west and I do
believe there's also a clear explicit
war in Christianity the the question is
I just don't understand how I mean one
question is the rate at which this is
happening is scary fast this
transformation this this great
replacement and it is a replacement it's
real it's happening we're not seeing it
in America like they're seeing it in
Western Europe to the same extent but we
still are seeing it nonetheless and it
actually reminds me of this weird video
I saw from some par some there was some
City councilors I believe in Finland I
think this week they put out a video
it's an all female city council they're
dancing around in the video and they're
and they're you know doing all these
weird gestures and the caption is this
Finland city council they would rather
make videos telling migrant men to you
know basically not rape women instead of
actually just shutting the border and
shutting their country and saying we are
going to protect our values our way of
life and most importantly our people and
I don't know when that became a sin but
for at some point along the way in the
west it became frowned upon to talk
about protecting our you know value
system our way of life our moral
framework and on the point you made too
about multiculturalism I think the big
Awakening I hope this is happening for
people this whole idea maybe it started
out as multiculturalism but like you
said with the politics of convenience
it's going to end in a monoculture it'll
just be dominated by the Muslim people
and their values and their way of life
as opposed to maybe you know influenced
by the Christian worldview and the
Christian ethic and the Christian Mythos
so this this idea of some Multicultural
Utopia does not exist this is not real
this is a fantasy that we can all just
live together in this morally neutral
amorphous soup and we can all have
different value systems and radically
different ideas about what constitutes
right and wrong or good versus evil and
somehow we'll just be able to figure it
out and live together in this sort of
secular postmodern you know neoliberal
kind of landscape that doesn't exist
that's a fantasy one world viw one one
moral framework is always going to win
out and I'm afraid what Europe is
looking at right now is a replacement
like you allude to in your article a
replacement of their traditional
Christian moral framework with this new
Islamic militant framework and I don't
know what that's going to look like but
I'm imagining Paris is some sort of is
Islamic you know police state kind of
place almost like a like a Saudi Arabia
I mean is that possible could we see
France be completely replaced to the
point where it's basically an extension
of the Islamic world because it seems
like that's what's going to happen at
some point yeah and see that's part of
the problem is if you live here in
America for example you really don't
know what's going on in Europe because
the same media that covers up and
engages in all the tactics to you know
present a whole different agenda from
what's really happening won't show you
what's really going on in places like
France like Paris like you mentioned or
in Vienna um you know and I remember
hearing Trump I think he mentioned Paris
once just in complete shock saying
that's Paris I don't even it doesn't
even look like Paris anymore um and he's
absolutely right but most people are
shielded from these massive demographic
shifts that are happening under
everyone's nose intentionally um and uh
you know it eventually it'll be too late
and that's the problem and that's
obviously the intention and the ultimate
goal you know is to keep people in their
own little bubbles um where they're more
you know like you said more interested
in creating little videos and I know the
video you're talking about it's a bunch
of Finnish women saying you know oh no
don't touch here some kind of cutesy
song That's supposed to U dispel you
know Muslim rapists from doing what
they've been doing in Finland and
elsewhere and it's you know I don't know
what to make of all that anymore other
than this is just pure suicide um and to
some extent if it does it almost
deserves to be destroyed if it stays the
way it is okay because you know this
sort of left this kind of insanity well
I mean I don't know that's not worth
preserving anyway if that's if that's
what the West means and has become then
you know okay uh but hopefully there's
still a kernel of uh its true Heritage
still there that can you know come back
and make a fight Ray unfortunately we're
out of time for this segment but I
really appreciate your insights and very
well done with the article
congratulations it really was a
fantastic read and I learned quite a bit